and thousands of flags found just in
time for Veterans Day and a woman who
places flags on Veterans graves in
Boulder City had the flag stored with
another person but she lost contact with
them until our story aired a few weeks
ago Victoria Saha Now with an update
flags on them to honor those who
sacrificed
a tradition that almost didn't happen if
these flags weren't found by Veterans
Day thank you buddy
we were trying to find each other and we
found each other are we in Don Kramer
didn't think was possible for weeks she
was trying to track down Dina Paddock
the two women met last Veterans Day when
they were honoring their fathers at the
cemetery Paddock volunteered to store
the 5 000 flags for Kramer just didn't
realize that so much time had passed it
was so awesome after losing products
contact information that is when Kramer
reached out to 8 news now hoping someone
somewhere would know Paddock she also
went to the cemetery Administration he
said could you please look up the uh the
seating of this grave that I have a
picture of because I put a flag on his
grave last year turns out Paddock was
also thinking of Kramer as we got the
phone call and she sent us the story and
we saw it there with dozens of
volunteers on Thursday to help out those
flags will be serving their purpose the
plagues isn't the most important to me
the honor is honoring each veteran one
flag at a time Victoria Saha 8 News Now